welcome to this video repo man the repo
man and he doesn't have the name in
there it's not closely by 1 i'm pretty
sure about that it's not a GM okay so
what we get here kali system at the
number of interesting options against
their okay yeah i should play with them
it's no particular reason to wait that
long yeah slate this g6 baseline quite a
bit okay yeah that is an interesting
line that i always forget to check that
you know white gets very nice
compensation here but it is not bad for
blankets just that it's very tricky to
play especially in blitz chess that
night on the six is very annoying I come
to see for here can I trade that night
we ate maybe I can put it on e6 to block
that c-47 diagonal
mmm that's not very comfortable that
position yeah I don't like to trade the
bishop but where am I going with the
Queen f6 also looks kind of awful
okay so Queen to d2 how do i get that
stuff coordinated 98 maybe can maybe
check on g7 and check me on c3 Queen
have 65 this kind of thing okay I don't
really see how I have to get rid of that
night them
huh yeah takes takes Queen c3 Queen f6
se5 I saw that move but somehow didn't
react to it no it's not doing them
wow it's the best that one has okay i'm
not saying that it is bad for him but I
was I don't know it felt it felt even
more dangerous than this 76 can I can
actually get in 97 okay I Bishop c4
something that I queen air force also
move now White has white has quite some
pressure still it felt even more awkward
but it is it is pretty pretty young
problematic as it is so 97 I guess yeah
Queen d6s Bishop g5 and I want and need
95 badly trading our stuff rookie 195
this kind of thing it should should
should be enough to to to equalize the
whole thing I hope okay I can take on c6
maybe okay still has that strong bishop
now I still has that strong bishop them
how do I play yeah I wonder I probably
have to go 95 otherwise I'm never
getting rid of never getting rid of a
pinata look T 1 we had the bishop on c4
it's just very very strong always
looking at that f7 pond the only way
yeah rupee Sam I guess
well okay so rook c8 all of what quindi
5s also know that i have rope t7
I can take it a look at the age right
because of his back rang time morning
okay that that that is set is equal now
no problem time problem but no no
position problem really
now okay that wasn't necessary i didn't
need to allow Queen Queen on the seventh
well that was it was very much
unnecessary and he's going to be five
coming yeah that was very stupid move
now that was very stupid there was
nothing going on really
I wanted to try for some activity but
he's always threatening made on f7 I
have a hard time to activate my queen
IAM yeah
ah I'm sure if the Queen trade was the
best for him to came in time wise he's
got some ideas as well check that wasn't
the best way to do it I guess yeah he's
so unfortunately covering both him both
pawns
I'm not coming into not getting into the
into the corner or something else it's
even the last five sets on time yeah
that was a very unnecessary loss after
heads defended that I mean here it's
just just nothing going on ah very
stupid yeah h5 is already a very stupid
way I can just do this and nothing
happens yeah I need to have some
something to attack after that there's
simply nothing going on I can take or
whatever it just it just totally equal
and just need to make sure that I gets a
little bit of space this is a bit bit
uncomfortable and this was this town
downright idiotic yeah allowing him to
go on that ub7 you know he can go eat
five but if I just stay here with the
King not nothing happens in that
position ever yeah I was under huge
pressure but I'm not sure maybe I was I
was okay yeah they're on the comp likes
my pollution actually and 95 was even
better interesting now I didn't consider
that move interesting
hmm yeah and really why is the engine
giving black a slight advantage here I
mean I'm maybe just reading that pawn
that could be the very simple
explanation but it's difficult to ever
claim something with the bishop here
sitting at your doorstep okay yeah this
is awkward but you never got anywhere
really you know just defense this loses
everything and this is equally bad so it
really only has that and here just
nothing happens I can also do this
actually that then also okay I can check
on yet okay that's not as convincing but
it doesn't matter any move g5 or
whatever is just drawing him okay oops
oops that was close to my coffee okay
well thanks for watching